>> EVEN THOUGH THINGS CAN BE
RESOLVING VERY WELL IN OTTAWA,
THIS STATE OF EMERGENCY IS NOT
OVER.
>> JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS NOT DONE
GOING AFTER THE CANADIAN
TRUCKERS.
POLICE BROKE UP THE CONVOY AND
ARRESTED NEARLY 200 PROTESTERS
THIS WEEKEND.
OTTAWA'S POLICE CHIEF SAID THEY
WILL TRACK DOWN AND PUNISH
ANYONE INVOLVED IN PROTEST.
>> IF YOU WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROTEST, WE WILL ACTIVELY LOOK
TO IDENTIFY YOU AND FOLLOW UP
WITH FINANCIAL SANCTIONS AND
CRIMINAL CHARGES, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS INVESTIGATION WILL GO ON
FOR MONTHS TO COME.
>> TRUCKERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ARRESTED ARE DEALING WITH THE
FALLOUT OF FROZEN BANK ACCOUNTS
AND SEIZED ASSETS.
>> THEY'VE TAKEN MY TRUCK.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT IS.
ON FRIDAY THEY LOCKED UP MY
PERSONAL AND TRUCKING BUSINESS
ACCOUNT.
AND ALSO WE HAVE ANOTHER
BUSINESS AND THEY LOCKED THAT
ACCOUNT UP, TOO, AND IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> GONNA TAKE EVERYTHING FROM
YOU BECAUSE YOU SPOKE UP.
>> RIGHT.
>> DANA, YOU KNOW ABOUT HANDLING
A CRISIS.
COMMUNICATIONS.
>> I CAN WRITE A BOOK OF HOW NOT
TO HANDLE A CRISIS AND JUSTIN
TRUDEAU WOULD BE ON THE COVER.
WHAT REALLY BOTHERS ME IS THE
GENTLE MAN YOU JUST SAW.
HE HAS A SEPARATE BUSINESS, HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PROTEST
AND THEY SEIZED THOSE BANK
ACCOUNTS AS WELL.
HE CAN'T MAKE ANY SORT OF
LIVING.
I THINK IT'S OUT AGEOUS FOR THEM
TO SAY THEY ARE GOING TO TRACK
PEOPLE DOWN FOR MONTHS.
THEY LEFT.
THEY ARE NO LONGER THERE.
CRISIS, SO TO SPEAK, IS OVER.
I ALSO WONDER ABOUT WHERE ARE
THE PRO BONO LAWYERS TO HELP
CHALLENGE THESE ACCOUNTS BEING
SEIZED.
I DON'T KNOW CANADIAN LAW, BUT I
WOULD ASSUME EMILY CAN SAY.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME WAY TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THAT.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE CELEBRITIES
THAT SAID THEY WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO CANADA IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED.
I'LL GUESS THEY ARE HAPPY THEY
LIVE IN A COUNTRY WHERE THEIR
PROPERTY CAN BE SEIZED.
>> TALKING ABOUT SEIZING BANK
ACCOUNTS.
ONE GUY SAID THEY SEIZED ASSETS
OF A BUSINESS THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH HIS TRUCKING
BUSINESS.
THIS IS RETALIATION.
WHAT WOULD WE DO IF THE
GOVERNMENT CAME AFTER US FOR
EXERCISING OUR 2ND AMENDMENT.
>> THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A 2ND
AMENDMENT.
>> YOU KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY,
CANADA HAS A LOT OF BRITISH DNA
IN THEM.
THEY NEVER REBELLED AGAINST THE
MONARCHY LIKE WE DID.
I ONLY SAY THIS HAVING BEEN TO
CANADA TWICE.
I LOOKED INTO THEIR LEGAL
SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT LIKE LIKE THE FREEDOM
WE HAVE HERE.
THEY DON'T TAKE THINGS
SERIOUSLY.
THEIR GUN CONTROLS ARE HYPER
STRICT.
YOU CAN'T EVEN LEAVE YOUR HOUSE
WITH A HANDGUN IN CANADA.
THE GOVERNMENT RUNS THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM OVER THERE.
HATE SPEECH IS A CRIME.
WHEN WE THINK OF THINGS
HAPPENING IN CANADA, IT'S NOT
JUST SOME COLDER VERSION OF
AMERICA.
THIS IS A RADICALLY DIFFERENT
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
WE ARE SHOCKED WHEN WE SEE THAT.
SEIZED ASSET OF AMERICANS
BECAUSE YOU FORGED SOME CHECKS
OR YOUR BACK TAXES HAVEN'T BEEN
PAID WITH THE IRS.
YOU DONATED TO A PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
IF THAT WOULD HAPPEN ANYWHERE IN
THE NORTHERN HEMISPHERE, IT'S
CRAZY.
SO IF AMERICA WANTS TO BE
RESPECTED AS A BEACON OF
LIBERTY, GERALDO, WHEN COMMUNIST
COUNTRIES DO THIS, WHEN
DICTATORS DO THINGS LIKE THIS,
FREEZE ASSETS, GO DOOR TO DOOR,
PUT PEOPLE IN PRISON FOR
PEACEFUL PROTEST, WE SPEAK UP.
WE SHOULD SPEAK UP.
THAT'S RIGHT UP THERE, GERALDO.
WE SHOULD BE SCREAMING.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN SPEAKING UP.
I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING
TO STICK WITH THESE TRUCKERS NOW
THAT THEY NEED YOU FOR THEIR
LEGAL DEFENSE.
YOU WERE EGGING THEM ON.
>> GERALDO, IT'S OVER.
>> I WAS ARRESTED AFTER PASSING
THE BAR, TAKING THE BAR JULY
1969.
I WAS TOTALLY DELAYED BECAUSE OF
MY PROTEST PARTICIPATION.
THERE'S CONSEQUENCES.
YOU SHUT DOWN A COUNTRY -- WHEN
YOU SHUT DOWN A COUNTRY AS THEY
DID IN CANADA.
>> YOU'RE SAYING FREE SPEECH,
ALTHOUGH IT EXISTS BUT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THERE, SHOULD
RESULT HAVING YOUR LIVELIHOOD
SHUT DOWN.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
HORSE TRAMPLING.
WE'LL GET INTO THE IMMIGRATION.
IT'S ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN CANADA
FOR 3 1/2 WEEKS.
THE PEOPLE OF OTTAWA WERE
TOTALLY INCONVENIENCED.
THEY HAD TRUCKS RUNNING ALL
NIGHT LONG, HORNS BLOWING.
PEOPLE WORE MASKS.
THEY WERE BEING MADE FUN OF BY
THE PROTESTERS.
YOU PAINT THEM LIKE THEY ARE
ROBINHOOD.
>> WAIT WAIT.
YOU'RE SAYING PROTESTERS DID
THAT?
>> THEY HARASSED.
IF YOU HAD A MASK ON --
>> LOOK AT THAT SISSY!
LOOK AT THEM!
YOU JUST MADE FUN OF KAMALA FOR
THAT.
>> I REMEMBER NOT THAT LONG AGO
THERE WERE PROTESTS THAT WE
WOULD GO ON THIS CHANNEL SAYING
WE SUPPORT THAT PROTEST.
WHEN IT TURNS INTO THE RIOT, THE
POLICE SHOULD COME IN.
THEY DIDN'T COME IN.
IT GOT UGLY REALLY QUICK.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED UP THERE.
INSTEAD, MOST PEOPLE LEFT.
THE ONES WHO DIDN'T GET ARRESTED
-- POLICE CHIEF GONNA HUNT YOU
DOWN AND BRING CONSEQUENCES.
THAT'S VINDICTIVE, IS IT NOT?
>> THE REASON THAT YOUR BAR
LICENSE WAS HELD UP.
YOUR LICENSE IS SUSPENDED,
TERMINATED OR NOT INSTATED IF IT
IS A CRIME FOR ALL PURPOSES.
PROTESTING UNDER PROTECTED FREE
SPEECH IS NOT THAT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
INCONVENIENCE CANADIANS SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF THESE PEACEFUL
PROTESTER, THAT PALES IN
COMPARISON WITH HAVING A VOICE.
YOU DO THAT VINE LYNN, GERALDO,
BUT THIS IS PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD,
PEOPLE'S CONVICTIONS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE LIVELIHOOD OF
THE AUTOWORKERS WHO DIDN'T GET
THEIR PARTS BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE
CLOSED THE BRIDGE?
>> THAT'S A MINOR INCONVENIENCE.
>> HE ALSO DOESN'T WANT A
GOVERNMENT TELLING HIM HE SHOULD
GET A VACCINE OR VACCINATE HIS
KIDS.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE REST OF THE
CONVERSATION.
IT'S NOT JUST THE INCONVENIENCE
OF THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
OTTAWA OR WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> JUST AS A QUICK FINAL POINT,
THE SUPREME COURT HERE,
OBVIOUSLY, HAS ENSURED POLITICAL
DONATIONS ARE PROTECTED BY FREE
SPEECH.
CANADA DOESN'T HAVE THAT SAME
PROTECTION.
THERE'S A BIG ARGUMENT THAT
FINANCIAL DEPLATFORMING IS THE
NEXT STEP OF THIS ONLINE
CENSORSHIP THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED SORT OF BY SOCIAL
MEDIA, BY PAY PAL AND WHAT NOT
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS
PERSON OFF, DENY THEM.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING THE MAGNITUDE
AND RIPPLE EFFECT OF THESE
PEOPLE'S LIVES BEING
CATASTROPHICALLY EX-
PEXPUN
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO KEEP
ON.
THE PET RELINQUISHMENT THING